Today we are going to talk about a
rather serious topic,
the future.
Hello again and welcome back. This is
Hoff here with Papa Northern Colorado
and the Autoropad G2 Turbo. Today we're
working on a 2023
Chevrolet Silverado with the new style
procs. Have a CANFD adapter installed
and plugged into OBD.
I've just updated it a little bit ago.
So on this one, that is the learning
slot. Looked in the owner's manual to
confirm. Can't remember if it's going to
work in that direction or not. So I may
end up needing to work it around a
little bit, but all right. Immobilizer
by vehicle. Chevrolet USA
Silverado 22 and up. Free pin.
All right. So,
going to keep opening closing the door
while it tries to communicate.
It is connected to the internet.
And this is all keys lost.
It is still connected. Yes.
Make sure all keys are away from the
sensing area.
So, ignition can't be turned on.
No, he found.
[Music]
So, just going to open the door,
close it,
close all doors.
Got the ignition on.
[Music]
All right. Now, we'll be back in about
10 minutes. And we're back. Configuring
system. Please wait a few seconds.
All right. Put the key into the
induction zone, which is not the cup
holder on this one. It is there. Other
keys away.
Key learning active. Press start button
for two seconds.
Ready
for key two, which means it took the
first one.
All right, second key in.
Current number of keys one. Do you need
to program more keys? Yes,
new key is in.
Okay,
press the start button.
Current number of keys too. Do you need
to program more keys? No. Configuring
system.
All right. Press and hold start button
for 16 seconds.
Turn off the ignition. Open the door.
[Music]
So, ignition is off. Open the door.
Close the door.
Please wait for 40 seconds. But while
that's going,
get the other key out.
We got our two keys there.
In the interest of accuracy, I'm not
going to skip past this and try and
start it yet. I'm just going to keep
going
as long as it wants to configure the
system so it doesn't pop a theft light
or anything.
Now, if you'll notice, the hazards are
still going, but it's not making the
noise anymore.
And now that noise popped back up again.
So I try and keep that noise always
going
and you're trying to get the programmer
to wake up the dash
and say
key left in vehicle. So it is
recognizing both the keys.
Programming finish.
[Music]
2023 Chevrolet Silverado. All keys lost
with auto propad and CAN FD connector.
Thanks for watching.
[Music]